[Music]
pretty good Tim Dillon was on uh H3 show
let's talk about this one you ready for
this one I don't even know okay I know
what you did no I'm just kidding it's
not about that uh Andrew Tate I want to
talk to you about yes
so you see did they banned him on
everything he's banned on everything
I know you did love that I love it well
I love it he's so hateable he he leans
into it now see the problem with Ethan
Klein the reason that you don't see me
really like even us like really ever
cover him that much and we cover him
tangentially if it's something else that
you know that's important but
it's because I am now of the thought and
please correct me if I'm wrong I am now
of the thought that he does this on
purpose like it's not it's not even that
he genuinely believes it I believe he
likes being the bad guy I think he looks
like Hassan [ __ ] is a lot a lot the
same way like that way right that's what
I feel like so that's why I don't really
even get too heated with him because I'm
like oh I'm getting mad at a wrestling
heel the only difference is this
wrestling heel is actually
de-platforming people so that's a really
good point that's the difference there
but but you understand what I'm saying
like I think he wants people to be mad
at him I think he wants people to make
fun of him that he wants people to do
that that way he has another reason to
go after you too you know well yeah I
know I got to agree with trap in the in
the in the chat too that you notice that
they downplayed it you didn't say he
wasn't banned from Rumble
numbers he got bro
he fought Rumble record
that you love it but I I just worry
about
you know number one is he that crazy
that you would ban him Yes Yes actually
I have Clips because I wanted to
persuade you you don't need to agree
with me for sure in my opinion I'm
always
reluctant to ban anyone right because
yeah and I think honestly I gotta say
yeah because a lot of people go oh well
they're gonna ban him they're going to
start Banning everybody right but the
people who have been truly deep
platformed yeah kind of deserved it
I'm trying not to I know I'm trying you
see me trying because I know he wants
the reaction and I just said I know what
he's doing I know he's Marsh
he's doing it on purpose but part of him
does believe this too man yeah I know I
know I know
I'll just breathe I got it we'll be all
right we'll be right we'll get through
this oh I wish wish that it was Rumble
Fridays
I don't know much about I know he says a
lot of wild stuff I haven't heard
anything where I'd go he should be
banished
yeah okay well here let's see I mean
you've
let's see um
I know you've seen a lot of these ones
because I saw you talking about it in
your clip oh this video is not available
[Music]
[Music]
he's just cringy like I don't understand
what the problem is being kind of cringy
doesn't mean you don't you're not
allowed to be on the [ __ ] internet
doing sex trafficking
yeah well I mean listen if that that
needs to be handled by Authority wait
they're accused him of sex trafficking
but that's the thing that they keep
doing the shutdown Tate right is he's
had a bunch of people he runs cam sites
and does this camera and [ __ ] and a
bunch of people on the internet that
don't like him who kept reporting them
and now now they're using the he's under
investigation for sex trafficking excuse
me the way of shutting them down excuse
me Ethan you piece of [ __ ]
um you're for sex workers and he was
employing them what's your problem
and again I'm not saying he should be
like a senator right right go ahead
[Laughter]
okay that's
it's pretty funny yeah
you take into context also that he's
done sex trafficking does it change your
well and and yeah I mean that's the
embassy
what do you think I'm gonna be like well
that's not a big thing even if you think
that maybe that video was just trolling
yeah like knowing the full scope of okay
Hey listen here uh [ __ ]
massage Soldier I want to explain
something to you here even if even if if
he does he's under investigation for
that you are innocent until proven
guilty so you don't get to BD platformed
because of that
this is what they do to the clients
remember what they try to do with
Assange and said that he was a pedophile
remember that and it turned out it was
all [ __ ] there was no proof of it
that's what they do they throw these
things and they go oh that's the reason
why then you find out the person never
did the thing look if he's under
investigation okay then bring up a case
is he under arrest right now no he's not
okay I also remember the New York Times
said that Matt Gates was going to go to
jail for for sex trafficking same thing
it's been almost two years now how come
it hasn't happened
because they they use these distractions
they throw it to people that they don't
like to take them down they think he
deserves it and that's the problem
here's the thing the same way that that
this
woman is is saying these things I can't
then you know what I could say hey I
know you served in the Israeli military
and you know what I've actually seen
them kill Palestinian kids did you I
mean I don't know you have maybe you
have maybe you haven't I don't know but
you never I don't know but you know
because you may have though you
shouldn't be allowed on the internet
this is this is that that level
of
anybody I don't like shouldn't be on the
internet and then the best part is then
having the sheer [ __ ]
arrogance right the sheer [ __ ]
arrogance the hubris
to think that you get to be the Arbiter
of it right like you are they are the
ones that get to decide for whatever
reason they're so morally Perfect Right
these Angelic creatures that by the way
started their YouTube career by making
fun of other YouTubers like we do now
like everybody else does that's what
they did too they made fun of them and
they call them names and they in front
of midgets
they did
all those things are true
um but now but now because now they've
you know they figured it out and then
now they made apologies to trans people
for feeling left out now they police the
internet and now they don't want you to
exist and by the way if you don't think
that's true go check it go check in on
some of these guys not just I'm not just
talking about Ethan but Hassan Pike or
or or any of these young Turks people go
check out their edits when they don't
want when they want you gone they will
post a link to your YouTube and say I
want this guy they will which is against
the rules but they always are they're
always allowed to do it yeah and they
will organize and they will say flag
this and flag this until your channel is
gone
and that's what they do and that's what
they that's what they do but here's the
problem and there's the truth and I
think Andrew take the Andrew Taylor
Rumble thing really I think changed a
lot because it showed a lot of people
leave YouTube and go to other places and
they'll get a fraction of their people
Andrew Tate left and he took his entire
audience with him right I think we're
getting to the point now and we're
getting to the place now where you're
gonna keep keeping people off of YouTube
and we're gonna get to the place now
where now people are just gonna start
following because Andrew take might have
been cringy he might have been all these
things but at the end of the day all he
was and that's the thing with Andrew
Tate like this this like this new thing
they're pretending Andrew Tate is a new
thing
an Andrew tank comes around every five
to ten years right like we've had one
Hunter more was the last Andrew Tate can
you remember him no but at my but you
know what I'm saying before of course
like that this is this is he's a [ __ ]
updated like version of like a thing
that we've seen so many prototypes of
which is Mystery remember mystery the
pickup artist like like
um the the hunter more you brought up uh
talker Max remember talker Max is a
great example so and and again that
being said uh and I think Tucker mask
could be funny sometimes he's funny on
Twitter sometimes pretty funny actually
but my my thing is is like
this is they're acting like that that
Andrew Tate is a new thing there's
always been dude empowerment guys
there's always been dudes that said
women suck I mean honestly Andrew Tate
hasn't said anything that black guys
haven't said on fresh and fit right but
listen to [ __ ] fresh and fit all they
[ __ ] talk about is how women are hoes
and how they suck and they're [ __ ]
and you know don't listen to these hoes
and they suck but they're fine because
you know hey the rappers and the rappers
go on the show and they're black guys
and it's cool has Andrew Tate really
said anything poorly about women you
want to talk about sex trafficking man
fresh and fitness have have had some
hookers be on their show that I'm not
saying they are but definitely look like
they might have showed up here in a
container ship
[Laughter]
straight from [ __ ] straight from the
[ __ ] Pacific Ocean and by the way
after after the Andrew Schultz fresh and
fit thing I don't even hate fresh and
fit I'll be that either I think they
stood their ground pretty hardcore when
they were just they were trying to talk
[ __ ] on them you know they could be
cringy too we could be cringy everybody
can be but like the the point is with
with this is like I would rather deal
with a million Andrew Tates and cringy
[ __ ] fresh and foot hooker shows and
and Brendan shobs out my ass then deal
with one Ethan Klein who just wants
people off the internet because because
he doesn't like them and then he and he
makes it happen it's not that he's
bitching about it is that he's done it
and I think to me that's the biggest
issue you know it's the it's this at the
end of the day they just want to get
people knocked off because they don't
want competition that's all it is yeah
they just don't want competition and if
they could knock off a bunch of guys
that are doing better than them yeah
then that's [ __ ] great for them and
then they end up making more money
because the people that they kick off
their fandom go hate watch their videos
yeah and all that means there's more
clicks and more views there's literally
no downside for him what downside does
he have I'm we're watching this video
right now to be mad at him
you know the only Solace we take is it's
only one view because it's my computer
and it's not yeah and all you guys get
to see it you know I basically feel like
I'm streaming a pay-per-view but
transformatively of course as you've
seen formally he's speaking of course of
course but but that's transformatively
speaking of course
um but but that's that's that's what
this is it's like all you want is people
not to be around and then you make up
these stories and these accusations do
you know do you know for sure he's sex
trafficked people are you just looking
at are you just looking at reports
because that's what you want to hear
that's the problem with that man I
wouldn't even care if Ethan Klein did an
entire five-hour episode making fun of
ripping apart calling Andrew Tate a
piece of [ __ ] nobody would care fine do
it
but people care the moment you say
you're incapable of doing that though
that's his problem he is incapable of
doing that so it's like well let's just
get him taken down
true that's true where you draw the line
sure do you think for example Isis
should be able to have a tick tock
Channel well Isis has a Twitter
yeah I say it's a Twitter next question
and by the way can I can I just I'm
sorry because God damn it
comparing Andrew Tate to Isis
it's a little odd
Isis treats women much better
[Music]
[Laughter]
an engine take can actually fight it's a
good point yeah
talking about people dancing then yes
they're radicalizing people they're
talking about like infidels and we need
to Stone infidels you you know if you
don't jump
straw man argument you're comparing
you're preparing an international
terrorist organization a [ __ ] a
pickup artist
like I mean I'm sorry but those two
things are not
yeah they don't they don't add up there
but I'm sorry but [ __ ] I I at least
to my knowledge Andrew Tate's not
driving around in a Toyota pickup truck
with a [ __ ] RPG on his shoulder you
know
well I mean that we know of yeah true
Romaine is a pretty wild Place true uh
sure you're gonna go to hell but you
might have to delete a lot more channels
than Isis if you were going to apply a
very broad definition but that doesn't
happen well and by the way Andrew tastes
not even a big conservative guy either
because he said some bass things but
he's not either you know honestly the
most conservative thing Andrew Tate has
been in is Jordan Peterson's daughter
tastes like meat sweats Jesus Christ
there's a lot of tastes like me sweats
looks like Daddy Issues clerics Islamic
clerics that are in the UK that say very
similar things to that right are they on
Tick Tock probably I mean I you could
easily pull up ten incredible yeah let
me just uh
yeah I don't think they should be
allowed to do that yeah because it's
hate speech right well it depends on
what they're saying I think it's the
hate speech thing gets very blurry right
yeah because like if you criticize
certain uh people in you know a war for
example right you there's you know for
example they allowed the social media
companies allow people to say things
about Russian people not only Putin they
were able to say hateful things about
Russian people during the onset of the
Russia Ukraine war they were they were
kind of allowing some more of that stuff
right so I think it's really that these
these you're saying you couldn't support
Russia no you could say anything you
wanted you used to not be able to talk
you used to not be able to talk about
the Nazi regime that Ukraine had on
Facebook this is a fact they didn't let
you because the ass off Battalion was
one of those things that was considered
white supremacist group and if you were
in it you were a white supremacist and
you were bad and then Facebook changed
their rules to allow you to be able to
post the ass off Italian stories and
flags and everything about them so yeah
100.
100 these things happened
but but that's the thing with Ethan even
when you confront him with like bro here
look here look these things did happen
he'll be like well no they didn't well
now well no no they're not censoring
conservatives on Twitter I like that you
just go well nah nah because that's kind
of what he's doing that's his argument
is nah nope nope meh no it didn't happen
no who's more vile Ethan or Hillis a
battle cat asked in the rumble chat
Ethan Ethan
eat Ethan's more vile I mean she's awful
too but rush you can say kill a little
rush you can say all that stuff I think
a lot of these standards are unevenly
applied because it's very difficult to
apply standards evenly how is it I'm
confused about what were people being
censored about in the Ukraine no they
weren't they weren't for example you
were saying if there's if there's hate
speech and you go what constitutes that
because it's it's I think what
constitutes that is you know calling for
violence or okay Andrew Tate hasn't
called for violence yeah violence
against you know I think harassment for
example doxing and harassment targeted
harassment of people and doxing are very
easy to identify hey wasn't it wasn't it
Ethan that was talking about blow
Someone putting a bomb at a republican
convention am I correct by saying that
oh yeah he was it was like it was on
that show he did with uh the NRA
convention then Eric that's what it was
and he said well yeah can't we just bomb
can somebody just bomb that place and he
got away with that so using no he
actually ended up that he did get
actually a strike for that but it was
you know it was cleaned up real quick
and then you know he was back in
business I see so he's allowed to do
whatever he wants yes got it okay if I
and shouldn't be tolerated but people
saying hateful things about each other
or it's more about targeting a group of
people right sure the top comment on
this video I just looked at it
Andrew Tate isn't band he's in every H3
video
that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] great that's very funny
baby top [ __ ] comment two by the way
keep this in mind 2.8 000 uploads
fifteen thousand down votes but hear me
out and by the way for his Clips this
video has more views than any one of his
normal Clips does right because it's
just this clip Channel yeah
um
what but this is why we were saying
earlier
he still wins
he's getting ad Revenue
he still wins see they're gonna now
people are gonna go watch him and be
angry at him because he knows what he's
doing he knows what he's doing
a lot of Ethan's not stupid this is
another thing there's another mistake
the same mistake people make with Ben
Shapiro I think Ben Shapiro is stupid
but Shapiro is not a stupid it's not
stupid Ethan Klein is not stupid they
are smart
and they know how to work the system and
they know how to make friends and they
know how to stay on a platform about
doing the very thing that you're doing
while you get kicked off and you have to
be somewhere else now again I'm starting
to feel very cozy on Rumble so I don't
really care but that being
that being said
what happens when it gets uh you saw the
truth social was kicked off of The Apple
Store
was yeah well that's you figure there's
always going to be a time when they
start doing that [ __ ]
sorry about that [ __ ] me
this is dying everybody
I took a hit but you know what it hit
when it hits the Rock Spot like hit the
back of my throat [ __ ] God damn it
anyway I'm all right yeah
also like let's acknowledge that these
are private companies it's not whatever
they want it's not even really no there
it is it's a private company they could
do whatever they want so basically he
dropped this entire argument from the
FBI comes to the private company and
says do this and they do it yeah with
the other part about that yes that's
true but the other part about that is is
it's not just a matter of it's a private
company they they can they can do
whatever they want the real Pro the real
thing that people have to notice is he
started this conversation saying he was
going to show him things about Andrew
Tate that was going to make him change
his mind when he didn't change his mind
he immediately went to well they could
do whatever they want so it doesn't
matter why are we even talking about
this the moment he was confronted with
some real truths like okay but explain
this and explain that he has to go I
don't even explain anything because
they're a private company
I do whatever I want I mean it doesn't
matter I win it's just enraging man
Ethan Klein's the kid from Big Daddy
that he's always playing I win and
there's nothing yeah that's the name of
the game I win I win this is [ __ ]
absolutely do whatever they want the
government on Twitter it'd be a whole
different conversation the government
owns Twitter they do own Twitter but
government subsidizes Twitter the
government pays for Twitter the
government gives a tax break the
government goes and threatens Twitter
and tells them to take people down when
the government wanted Alex Jones off of
all the social media platforms it
coordinated and made it happen what are
you talking about if the government on
Twitter go [ __ ] yourself
are you kidding me Google is winning
non-compete contracts with the
government and we're pretending to
Google and YouTube are separate from the
government at this point we're still
playing that stupid game
come on this isn't a mom-and-pop
lemonade stand that's kicking you out
because they don't want you to be there
dance not five dollars good to see you
homos on Rumble I can be more happy can
be more homophobic over here love you
okay well thank you
um
there's like 33 minutes we could keep
going if you want but honestly it's kind
of just a
this six minutes that we just saw
repeated over and over again using
different words
and at the end of it
nobody's mind has changed
you know like the internet
yeah that's life this is what this is
what our lives are right